[Musica]
non c'è abbastanza
infanzia qualche anno fa ho letto una
frase di un autore afgano che diceva più
o meno così nel mondo ci sono tanti
bambini e bambine ma non c'è abbastanza
infanzia inizialmente non ho subito
compreso il significato di questa frase
mi sembrava forse un po' troppo dura
cruda poi negli anni e soprattutto
grazie ad alcuni incontri ho capito un
po' meglio la portata di questa
frase Oggi ho portato con me alcune
fotografie d' alcuni oggetti che spero
possano aiutare anche voi Così come
hanno aiutato me a farvi capire la trama
che in questi anni ho dato a questa
frase settembre 2020
eravamo all'interno del campo rifugiati
di
lavrio muri alti e filo spinato è
difficile immaginare che dentro un campo
rifugiati possano esserci dei bambini è
così molto spesso quando facciamo le
missioni umanitarie siamo soliti
organizzare dei workshop educativi per
cercare di restituire a questi bambini
delle bambine dei momenti di gioia di
spensieratezza
eravamo all'interno del campo e stavamo
giocando una partita a
calcio Quando ad un certo punto abbiam
visto un bambino che era sempre distante
isolato così con i miei colleghi le mie
colleghe siamo andate da lui e l'abbiamo
invitato a giocare una partita a
calcio
camaran 6 anni Siriano non aveva mai
giocato una partita di calcio prima di
allora
camaran 6 anni Siriano non sapeva che
cosa significasse giocare a
calcio sei disegni perché ve li sto
mostrando hanno alcune caratteristiche
in comune prima tra tutte sono stati
realizzati da bambini e da bambine
durante le nostre missioni umanitarie in
contesti di emergenza
poi le figure rappresentate da questi
bambini non
sorridono nonostante poi portiamo sempre
tutti i colori abbiamo notato che i
colori più utilizzati per disegnare sono
i colori scuri soprattutto il colore blu
che è il colore del
mare il tratto poi risulta essere un
tratto non uniforme segmentato sinonimo
di ansia
inquietudine l'utilizzo dello spazio poi
questi bambini non disegnano in tutto il
foglio Bensì in piccole porzioni di esso
sinonimo di non sentirsi
compresi agosto
2021 eravamo all'interno del campo
rifugiati di
rizzon il campo de rifugiati di rizzon è
un campo molto particolare poiché
all'interno di esso ci sono centinaia di
rifugiati e rifugiate di etnie diverse e
quindi molto spesso ci sono anche dei
conflitti all'interno del
Campo ecco quel giorno dovevamo
realizzare un workshop di disegno quando
a un certo punto è arrivata
un'operatrice che ci ha detto Mi
raccomando Aspettate due bambini perché
ci tengo particolarmente che facciano al
workshop hanno avuto un passato
particolarmente atroce e così nonostante
stessero arrivando centinaia di bambini
e bambine da ogni angolo del campo
quando sono arrivati loro due L'ho
capito
subito era molto
caldo maglietta maniche lunghe pantaloni
lunghi due cappelli che coprivano quasi
interamente i
volti La mamma si è avvicinata e mi ha
detto son vestiti così per non fare
impressione agli altri
bambini poi mi sono accorta che il
bambino aveva con sé un album da disegno
G ha iniziato a mostrarmi i suoi
disegni tra cui questo che vi Confido
che solitamente lo custodisco
gelosamente in camera
mia
Ecco questo io in quel momento sono
rimasta scioccata dalla capacità di
disegnare di questo bambino mi sono
detta Ma è così piccolo come
fa Poi ho
capito la mamma mi ha spiegato che quei
due bambini non avevano avuto solamente
la sfortuna di essere nati in
Afghanistan quei due bambini avevano
avuto anche la sfortuna che una volta
arrivati in Europa nella cosiddetta
rotta balc
nella loro nuova casa una tenda la loro
tenda aveva preso fuoco e così erano
totalmente ricoperti da cicatrici di
ustioni
gravi per questo non potevano giocare
con gli altri bambini all'aria aperta ed
esporsi al sole e così la loro mamma mi
ha raccontato che erano soliti passare
le loro giornate all'interno della loro
nuova tenda a disegnare
dicembre
2022 eravamo all'interno del campo
rifugiati afgano di lavrio Erano passati
pochi mesi dalla presa di Kabul da parte
dei
talebani molto spesso quando facciamo le
missioni umanitarie siamo soliti anche
portare beni di prima necessità se serve
come vestiti cibo
medicinali in quel momento stavamo
consegnando i di prima necessità le
famiglie afghane quando abbiamo
incontrato una bambina ija afghana di 4
anni non stava più nella pelle Voleva
aprire a tutti i costi lo scatolone
destinato alla sua famiglia e così
l'abbiamo aperto con lei e le abbiamo
fatto indossare questo vestitino blu
ia non riusciva a capire come fosse
possibile che quando girava su se stessa
il vestito si alzasse per
l'aria
isja
afghana di 4 anni non aveva mai
indossato un vestito prima di
allora ottobre
2022 eravamo in Gambia nel più piccolo
Stato dell'Africa e in uno dei 14 paesi
più poveri al
mondo 14 era anche il numero stampato
sul retro della maglietta di un bambino
che ci seguiva sempre durante le
missioni umanitarie
e quel giorno era l'ultimo giorno
eravamo all'ospedale di mandinari e
stavamo erogando Servizio Medico
gratuito Quando ad un certo punto ho
visto arrivare questo bambino di corsa
con un
bigliettino un numero era il numero
della sua mamma sapeva che il giorno
dopo saremmo tornati in Italia e ci
teneva che in qualche modo potessimo
rimanere in
contatto Ecco da quel giorno sono decine
le videochiamate che ricevo ogni
settimana da parte di quel numero C'è un
problema
però il segnale lì a mandinari è
talmente poco che nonostante io accetti
le videochiamate queste non riescono mai
ad avviarsi
è così Mi piace pensare che ogni
videochiamata che ricevo da parte di
questo numero sia un canto libero da
parte della Comunità di mandinari che mi
dice Non dimenticarti di
noi nel mondo ci sono tanti bambini e
bambine ma non c'è abbastanza
infanzia settembre
2023 manca 30 giorni alla nostra
ripartenza per le missioni umanitarie
perché noi non ci siamo dimenticati di
loro
Grazie